attention toi tu fais ça j'ai confondu
s'est encore fendu
ça fait trois semaines qui se prépare
pour cette mission
il a regardé le match le moment venu
après mais je pense pas je pense que m
j'ai deux fils guillaume j'avais si
j'avais été un arctique en tête au
centre de formation je me suis fait
spécialement nuit
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est aux rebelles vous êtes
concentré ses premiers souvenirs
ma première ivresse
ah bon c'était corps c'était peu ça fait
dix on vous avait 22 ans
premier choc
j'aimais quand j'ai récité une poésie
dans ma classe cité en ce2 ah oui et ça
vous ça vous a plu vous ai dit c'est ça
que je veux faire 90 a vraiment fait
j'ai eu une part monstrueuse quoi les
mensonges ne sais pas et c'est pas mal
le mensonge en ça permet d'inventer une
réalité meilleur je crois que je
pratique et très tôt c'est une proche
c'est une tranche comme elles sont
jetées lady avait fait hypokhâgne ans
n'a aucune chance
premier péché ya pas de pêcher ouais
le bc rien mes péchés rien premier amour
il faut que je dise quoi premièrement
j'ai donné le nom l'adresse saoudite il
avait pas en voilà quand c'est peu
touchés du petit j'imagine c'était non
j'étais pas si le titre que c'était un
garçon blond avec une queue de cheval
comme ça un petit bassin devant mon
collège
nous étions c'est un garçon premier
baiser sur un skateboard d'une acrobate
ce qu'il était tout petit avant premier
flirt poussé vers avec des avec la
langue et tout ça mais c'était c'était
c'était le premier de la queue de cheval
non c'était le scan bronn ce que pense
première idole aznavour peut-être
première belle robe
j'avais une robe en drap comme les
amours je sais qui c'est moi c'est celui
de nantes à qui vous est venue à paris
non ouais c'est ça
et alors alors ça devient chaud première
fois à 2 pour la fois que vous avez fait
l'amour à deux avec un garçon ou une
fille première fois des ventes en baisse
était le même garçon bon faudrait que
j'exerce sortir comme ça je vais pas
vous demander la première fois à troyes
parce qu'ici non parce que ça ici on est
ici on est discret non je demanderai pas
la première fois trois premières fois 4
jamais je n'ai pas encore essayé vous
avec 22 en même temps première rupture
première rupture c'était à 18 ou des
sucs et ronfler non ils reflètent je
peux vous demander à quel âge de les
filmer votre premier pétard parce que ça
c'est de la provocation facile première
ligne alors vous n'êtes pas obligé de
répondre premier succès premier succès
mais c'est là c'est là si mauvaise pour
ça que c'est à tout le monde voilà c'est
clair et bientôt la première la première
ligne premier échec
je le connais c'est terminal du giro un
seul et même voix la première chose que
vous faites le matin au réveil je prends
une douche et bien le que tu fais le
matin
moi je veux pas de douche jeu c'est un
truc je fais c'est inconscient j'ai vu
ça dans un film crtv jeu
je passe la main j'ai un grand chose
comme ça de foot et je me passe la main
mais c'est inconscient après je vois mon
café vient bien tu te tiens aucune
chance aucune chance avec plein de mecs
mais c'est inconscient c'est souvent on
fait sa dernière volonté si vous deviez
mourir là maintenant c'est important d'y
devenir un objet de venir à nancy avant
c'est tout c'est pas plus chaud que ça
mais c'est très chaud dimanche avant et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous il m'était impossible
ou